it's the year 2000 and vladimir putin
has just become the president of russia
after a decade of post-soviet
humiliation he starts reasserting his
country on the world stage
the timing's convenient oil prices are
soaring and that's boosting living
standards all across the country
eight years later putin has to leave the
presidency because of term limits
and does an interim stint as prime
minister
and by 2012 putin becomes president
again
now though following international
sanctions provoked by russia's
intervention in ukraine
as well as a collapse in the price of
oil living standards are falling
and that's putting his appeal to the
test this is the situation
putin is all about strength and it's his
strongman image that has helped maintain
his leadership
you can see it in his vast publicity
stunts whether it be
competing in martial arts riding
horseback or having his pet labrador
sniff angela merkel who
in case you couldn't tell isn't exactly
the biggest fan of dogs
in fact one of the only times he's shown
any softness was at his presidential
victory rally in 2012
and here comes the argument putin is
being tested by an economy that's
tanking
russia is facing its longest recession
in two decades
with real gdp falling by 3.7 percent in
2015.
meanwhile he's holding on to his former
kgb tough man image at home
abroad though he's recently tried
playing the role of a diplomat
after starting a bombing campaign in
syria to support his ally president
bashar al-assad
he's now working with the u.s to reach a
settlement there
he's also announced a partial military
pullback from the country
the question now is how will putin be
remembered
for his diplomatic flexibility or as the
unyielding ruler whose military
adventurism
hurt russia when its economy could least
afford it